were you the first choice for the
creators of Sex in the City or did you
have to go through the audition process
were there other women involved as a
potential leads for that series when it
started
um as Darren shared with me I I got I
got a script
um from my agent and he said Darren
Stars you know thinking about you for
this would you meet him he said I wrote
this with you in mind and I shared with
him that my only concern I thought the
script was really interesting and really
exciting and different and fresh and I'd
never seen anything like that and the
only thing I said to him that I was
concerned about was that I just didn't
feel comfortable doing nudity and I
suspected that if it wasn't in the pilot
it would be part of a series that it
felt like it was legitimately going to
be talked about and he said don't do it
then I don't care don't do nudity he
said we'll have other actors if they
feel comfortable doing it they'll do it
but you do not have to and I was like
were you not comfortable with nudity
because of your body image or were you
not comfortable with nudity because you
think it would make you in a different
category of actress
um I think I was just
shy I think I just never
felt
comfortable
um exposing myself that way and I never
had any judgment about anybody else
doing it wasn't like a morality thing or
if somebody else felt comfortable doing
it I kind of ad I was admiring of them
um but I just never felt comfortable
being nude I didn't think it would
change perception of me or kind of like
create opportunities that I might not be
interested in I just didn't I was shy
the other thing you were you put your
foot down I guess you said to Darren
Starr look I don't want to say [__]
I don't want my character to say [__]
in the first episode why we were on HBO
and I knew that that meant we could say
whatever we wanted and we could
be loose and liberal and salty and
rivaled and blah blah but I also thought
therefore it meant that we had to be
disciplined and we shouldn't just use
language because we could and Carrie
Bradshaw is a writer and she's really
really really thoughtful about what she
says how she says it when she says it
who she's saying it to and if if we want
to use language let's be really
thoughtful about when she uses it we can
be smart about it and I think it's been
good because when she's used language
it's
wow going back all those years you had a
pretty healthy movie career it's a big
decision to now go to HBO because back
in those days it was looked upon like oh
you're not a film actress anymore now
you're now you're a television actress
right it was like a big deal all I knew
really about television was that you had
to sign a seven year contract and you
showed up every day and you did 28
episodes a year and hi Scotty you drive
onto Universal hi Scotty the London
thing would open
in other words and it scared me
yeah because it scared you because you
probably said to yourself I really love
acting I don't want to take a job where
it becomes road and I was wondering that
too like look how many you've made two
films out of Sex in the City now you
have this series you've had many years
on sex in the city was there like some
hesitation at some point to say I I'm an
actress I want to go do something new I
don't want to keep playing you know
Carrie Bradshaw over and over again yeah
and I think what
happened originally was that I shared
these concerns with HBO it was hpf do
you remember them was like this very
small Network it was mostly male
dominated entertainment that were couple
scripted shows that were all male and
then it was Sports and your movies and
um I said I'm scared and Chris Albrecht
and and Carolyn Strauss said to me so if
you don't like it after a year we won't
do it like we don't have any advertisers
to answer to we'll just do it let's take
it year by year so then I was like and
then I went to work the first day of the
first season of the first episode and it
happened to be two blocks from my house
so I walked from my house went to the
set never looked back
foreign